because Paul what's a Junaid know David
Bowie Nala Dana I've always been a big
fan of everybody I think you know who
everybody talks about the you know
reinventing himself the Ziggy Stardust
Aladdin Sane then his soul period but
for me I think was just a brilliant
songwriter I don't think you need to
worry about all that nonsense do you
know that he was a fan of brilliance but
it was a fan of you well I don't like to
name drop but I will I've read a couple
of interviews with Tony Visconti and he
said that he you know he really liked
these two shows that I've done and that
he's a genuinely I'm not gonna name drop
maybe but that one yeah it was it was
really you know but there was one
ordinary but one character one character
in particular that he liked wasn't there
well I think you know you see did an
impersonation of one character that I
used to do yes this was the teenager no
is yeah the guy said you know
everything's brilliant and you know it's
a great mountain fantastic you know the
way just talks to people is brilliant
unzip just drink some wine you know and
then pushes people out that's a
fantastic
I used to do lease carriers that I said
everything was brilliant you know like
things aren't like telephones but then
weirdly you probably know this exists
but there was a documentary of their
very own tour and there was kind of you
know backstage bits and there's a clip
of him doing really bad in personnel how
early she is doing very bad impression
of you
sure does that's brilliant
flashy badge is brilliant but you see on
your ear and there go WOW brilliant
fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
you